[Roman] Are you gonna do something? [Kendall] I should. [Roman] Yeah
you should and the only way he'll respect
you is if you try to destroy him because in your
position that is exactly what he would try to do.
[Greg] Yeah I made copies of a few key documents
related to all that stuff in case I got into
any trouble at all. So yeah I would just think like
anybody would be wise to keep me in a good role.
Ah succession, the 20-hour experiment exploring
whether you can create a show populated
exclusively with unlikable characters and still
make the audience care about what happens to them.
20 hours and counting because there are new
episodes coming next week when Season 3 debuts.
And by the end of season 2, I would say that the
experiment has been a success. Today i'm gonna do
a refresher video if you didn't have time to do a
re-watch or if you just can't get enough of these
Roy family slime puppies. Of course this video
will contain spoilers if you haven't watched
the first two seasons. If you're just a viewer of
my channel and you're curious about Succession
I definitely recommend it. The first season
does take some time to get its feet underneath
it but it ends strong and then the show continues
to improve through the second season where it all
comes together at the end. And the season 3 reviews
that are out there all sound pretty positive.
The big question you might have is why do you want
to watch a bunch of awful people, and this isn't a
review, but i'll say real quick that it's written
well and there's a lot of different routes to
get into what's going on. you have family drama,
you have black comedy, you have wealth porn if
that's your thing, amazing locations, high stakes
business maneuvering, all propped up by stellar
performances across the board and some pretty
solid social satire to boot. if i were to cobble
some words together I would say that Succession
gives you a relatable dose of humanity without
humanizing the ghouls behind the drama. in other
words you can relate to the situations that the
unrelatable characters find themselves in. Season 2
ends with one of those. who hasn't found themselves
in a situation where you're trapped with your
family and it's not easy to get away? the Roys
can't get away because they're on their daddy's
super yacht and while everyone's coming together
to try to figure out what to do about the cruise
ship controversy, no one here is safe and everyone
involved arrives with different things on their
minds. Conor and Willa are fresh off opening night
of the play she wrote and he financed which
seems destined for a lackluster reception. Shiv
is coming off what I guess you would call a
victory for the family where she convinced the
sexual assault victim who was going to testify not
to go through with it. in an effort to spice things
up with her husband she's arranged a threesome
with one of the employees that works on the yacht.
Roman is coming off of a hostage situation more or
less that came out of a meeting that he set up in
an effort to get the financing to take the company
private. Kendall arrives in a pretty good place
he had the strongest showing at the congressional
hearings and he's got Naomi pierce with him as his
companion. Greg solidifies his place once again as
the outsider by not realizing that sails out means
nails out and he's got a nail fungus to deal with
on top of his terrible performance at the hearing.
that underlines the situation that Logan Roy
finds himself in and sets the table for what
they all end up on this boat to do. on his way
there Logan gets a call where he learns that the
position of some of his big shareholders is that
he should step down. to me it never seems like he
considers this even later when he throws it out
as an option in front of his family but we'll
come back around to that. the deal is the family's
still in the middle of the proxy fight after the
takeover that Kendall set in motion before he
had to pull back after killing the waiter in
the car crash at the end of the first season. the
shareholder meeting's coming up and Logan says he
needs one meaningful skull to wave which is to say
a sacrifice of someone important to take the fall
for the cruiser's cover-up. Logan lays it out there
and then the characters all take time to discuss
who should be the one to take the fall which
involves everyone getting their names thrown
out there to have everyone discuss why they'd be
a good candidate right in front of them all of the
non-family characters are at risk Roman goes after
Frank and then he defends Gerri who he's got this
secret relationship going on with but in the end
they decide it has to be somebody in the family
as I mentioned Logan offers himself up Kendall's
quick to jump in and say that it won't work though
primarily for stability after Rhea left when
she found out that logan definitely knew what
was going on with cruises and had no problem lying
to her about it Conor offers himself up because he
needs money which we'll come back to and at one
point it feels like Tom is the one that's gonna
get it because he was actually complicit with
destroying the documents and he did a terrible
job at the hearing in the process of deciding a
few things happen the way they got here was that
Rroman decided he didn't trust the people who
were gonna back their play to go private it's
a move that seems to earn him some points with
his father even though it takes an out for the
company off the table in general Roman appears
to come out of nearly being a hostage stronger
than when he went in and he even throws the idea
out there of treating each other better to his
siblings but they mock the idea and it ends there
in the last ditch effort Kendall and Logan meet
with Stewie to make him a generous offer which he
refuses while they're gone Tom and Shiv have some
alone time and he comes clean about how unhappy
he is in the marriage after she tried to assure
him that she wouldn't let anything happen to him
he makes it clear that he wasn't okay with finding
out that Shiv wanted an open relationship on their
wedding night and how he now wonders if the sad
he'd be without her would be less than the sad he
would get from being with her that marks the end
of her chances to take over as CEO as later she
loses points when she goes to Logan to ask him
not to use tom as the sacrifice things don't go
much better for the other Roys not named Logan
Connor hits his dad up for a hundred million to
help with things after he refuses to help with
positive reviews for Willa's play he has to endure
being crushed in the process and agree to drop out
of the presidential race, Logan makes Kendall send
Naomi away saying he wasn't properly informed and
that he just doesn't want ken on drugs it's
the last in a long line of awful things he's
had to endure this season starting with getting
pulled out of rehab and then being forced to go
into the house of the family of the kid that
died and it all sets things up nicely for the end
Logan arrives at his decision and tells Kendall
even though he did so well at the hearings he's
gonna have to be the face and that they'll create
a press conference where he can admit that he knew
everything directed the cover-up and that it
went no higher Kendall accepts this and then
asked his father if he ever thought he could do
the ceo job he says that he's not a killer he
stresses you have to be a killer and then ken
throws it out there that maybe he deserves it
for the boy who died and logan tells him to
forget that it's nothing there was no real
person involved echoing the language that was
used for covering up the cruise ship crimes
Ken assures everyone he'll be okay and then
he leaves to go back to new york with Greg
he arrives at the press conference to read the
prepared statement after describing why he's there
he drops a butt the butt hurt around the world
and goes off script calling logan a malignant
presence a bully and a liar and that he was fully
personally aware of these events for a number of
years he points out that his father always kept
tight control over everything that happened and
that he would never let settlements of millions
of dollars and payments go out to these people
without knowing about it and kendall has those
documents from greg to prove it back on the yacht
the family's watching and you see Logan's face
it's almost as if he starts to smile sitting
there seeing his son become a killer he did the
thing that it didn't seem like any of them would
be able to do go against their dad and really
try to bring his reign to an end Kendall had
tried to do it before and we saw how that played
out he spent most of the season as a punching bag
completely cowed and that kept the others in line
everything fell into place and Greg holding on to
those documents finally paid off of course Logan
won't go down without a fight his smile led some
viewers to guess that this might have been
his plan all along I tend to think it's more
of a callback to that season one clip i opened
the video with that he just couldn't help enjoy
seeing his son do what he would have done if the
situation was reversed I mean I see where people
are coming from and you can kind of make it work
if you go back and look at it that way but based
on how we've seen logan handle things leading
up to this point i think it would be somewhat
out of character he uses his money his power and
his influence to get what he wants and everything
sort of falls apart when that doesn't work think
of him walking out of the negotiation with Nan
Pierce when she tried to force him to name Shiv as
his successor which is something that he told his
daughter he'd do at the beginning of the season
and then you have to wonder if he just would have
told Kendall that he thought he could have been
the CEO would he still have followed through with
the plan? as it is it makes it exciting as hell to
see kendall turn the tables and it should be a lot
of fun to see where their battle goes from here
everything is up in the air and people are gonna
have to choose sides I think I'm most interested
to see how Roman handles it and what's to become
of Greg and Tom now that those documents came
into play and i think that's a great place to
leave things let me know in the comments what you
took away from the first two seasons of succession
and what you're hoping to see in the third
please like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon